>> ♪ ♪
>> Sean: BACK TO OUR TOP STORY.
THE HOUSE INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE
VOTEING TO RELEASE THE
CLASSIFIED MEMO THANKS TO YOU
CALLING YOUR CONGRESSMAN SAYING
MEDIA CONDEMNED THE MOVE.
THEY DON'T WANT TO SEE THE MEMO
AND THEY DON'T WANT YOU TO SEE
THE MEMO.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE REPUBLICANS DECLARED WAR
ON OUR NATIONAL SECURITY ON
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION.
>> WE ARE SEEING A BREAK DOWN OF
DEMOCRACY.
WE HAVE NEVER HAD A SITUATION IN
WHICH THE CONGRESS MOVED INTO A
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION AND
TURNED IT INTO A POLITICAL
CIRCUS.
THAT'S WHAT IS GOING ON HERE.
>> IT LOOKS LIKE WATERGATE.
IT ALSO HAS FRINGES OF THE SALEM
WITCH TRIALS AND THROW IN THE
McCARTY HEARINGS AND WE HAVE ONE
CRISIS ABOUT TO HAPPEN HERE.
>> Sean: JOINING US NOW FORMER
WHITE HOUSE PRESS SECRETARY FOR
PRESIDENT TRUMP SEAN SPICER AND
FORMER PRESS SECRETARY FOR
LET'S TALK ABOUT THE ORIGINS OF
THIS.
THIS IS IMPORTANT.
THE ORIGINS ARE SIMPLE.
WOULD YOU HAVE HAVE AN EMAIL
INVESTIGATIONS.
IT WAS WRITTEN MONTHS BEFORE
THEY INTERVIEWED MAIN
PRINCIPALS.
THEN WE HAVE A DOSSIER USED TO
INFLUENCE THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THAT WAS NOT TRUE.
AND IT WAS USED AS A FOUNDATION
TO GET A FISA WARRANT TO SPY ON
IN OUR LIFETIME.
IT'S SUCH A DANGER BECAUSE FISA
IS ALL ABOUT SPYING ON
AMERICANS.
YOU BETTER HAVE GOOD CAUSE THAN
RESEARCH THAT WAS NEVER
VERIFIED.
THE NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISOR
>> Sean: ONE A DAY.
>> THAT'S CORRECT, SEAN.
>> THE BUSH ADMINISTRATION NEVER
DID IT.
THE AMOUNT OF TIMES OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION DID NIGHT AND
DAY.
>> Sean: 300% INCREASE.
THAT'S ONE OF THE EARLY STORIES
WE BROKE.
>> SEAN, I THINK THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE NEED TO SEE.
IT WE NEED TO PUT ALL OF THE
FIXES IN SO WE PROTECT
SEIZURE.
WE HAVE TO VET OUT THOSE PEOPLE
WHO ABUSED THIS PROGRAM DESIGNED
TO KEEP AMERICANS SAFE.
>> THERE IS A BALANCE.
WE ARE NOT USING CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION AGAINST AMERICAN
CITIZENS IN A WAY THAT IS
ALLEGED.
WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE IT'S DONE
IN A WAY THAT DOESN'T REVEAL
SOURCES AND METHODS.
THE HOUSE SHOULD WORK WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO MAKE
SURE THIS IS DONE IN A
RESPONSIBLE WAY.
THERE IS TRANSPARENCY.
BUT WE DO SO IN A WAY THAT
DOESN'T BURN A LOT OF SOURCES
AND METHODS ARE THAT USED.
>> Sean: WE KNEW FOREIGN
INTELLIGENCE AGENCIES GOT AHOLD
OF CLINTON'S EMAIL SERVER.
>> I AGREE WITH THAT.
THAT GETS LOST IN THE MIX HERE.
JUST BECAUSE SHE DIDN'T WIN AN
ELECTION DOESN'T MEAN YOU DON'T
GET PROSECUTED.
>> Sean: DO YOU THINK THE FIX
WAS IN?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
A LOT OF THINGS BEING SAID IN
THE TEXT MESSAGES AND WHAT YOU
WONDER WHAT REALLY WENT INTO IT.
A REPORT IS COMING OUT IN MARCH.
THAT WILL BE REVEALING AS WHAT
REALLY HAPPENED INSIDE THE
DEPARTMENT.
LOOK, ONE OF THE THINGS THAT IS
INTERESTING ABOUT WHAT THE
DEMOCRATS ARE SAYING IS THAT IF
YOU QUESTION ANYBODY IN THE
THAT'S NOT TRUE.
99% OF THE PEOPLE WHO WORK DAY
IN AND OUT IN LAW ENFORCEMENT
ARE GOOD, HARD WORKING PEOPLE
WHO CARE ABOUT THIS COUNTRY
MORE THAN ONE OF THE EMAILS
HILLARY CLINTON SENT WENT TO
PRESIDENT BARACK OBAMA FROM HER
PRIVATE SERVER.
THE FBI CHANGED THE NAME.
THEY CLEANED IT UP TO PROTECT
BARACK OBAMA.
THEY COULD NOT HANDLE THE IDEA
THAT THE PRESIDENT KNEW HILLARY
AND THEY COVERED FOR HER.
THEY ARE USING HER PAID FOR
DOSSIER TO SPY ON AN OPPOSITION
DEFENDED ROBERT MUELLER.
I USED TO DEFEND JAMES COMEY ON
HIS INVESTIGATION OF HILLARY
CLINTON.
I CAN NO LONGER DO THAT.
THE INVESTIGATION INTO HILLARY
IS A SHAM.
ANYBODY WHO LOVES THE FBI, IN
THIS INSTANCE THE FBI LET US ALL